[Music]
footage and two together
I was lucky enough to play in three
World Cups and I know that I went into
each one of those World Cup
playing probably 50 to 60 games in the
seasons players are coming into this
world cup after playing 25 games in
their season so they're going to be
arriving fresh excited their energy is
going to be at top level so I think what
you're going to see on the pitch is
probably like no other World Cup
foreign
[Music]
it's the dream for fans it's a dream for
players because you know in past World
Cups again you know we've had to travel
we've had to do that kind of thing so
it's not easy to recover after games but
you know fans are going to be able to
watch
a lot more games fans are going to be
able to obviously travel less distance
but for players you know I would love to
be playing in in this world cup because
it's so close everything is so close
[Music]
[Applause]